tonight there are increasing calls for
the resignation of new york governor
andrew cuomo
after a third woman has accused him of
sexual harassment
state democrats are also getting closer
to taking away
some of cuomo's powers correspondent
brian yenis has been following this from
brooklyn continues tonight good evening
brian
good evening brett tonight new york's
democratic-controlled state legislature
announced it will repeal
governor andrew cuomo's emergency
pandemic powers
which have given him extraordinary
authority over new york's covet 19
response
it's the latest sign democrats are
beginning to revolt against one
of their leaders anna ruck provided this
photo to the new york times
both ruck and the times say it captures
the moment at a september 2019 wedding
when governor andrew cuomo put his hands
on her face
the 33-year-old says cuomo then asked if
he could kiss her
rux says she was confused shocked and
embarrassed
fox news has not independently confirmed
this information
and we've reached out to ruck in cuomo's
office ruck
is now the third woman to accuse
governor cuomo of sexual harassment in
the last week
now at least 13 democratic new york
state lawmakers and the new york working
families party a progressive party in
the state
are calling for cuomo's resignation new
york congresswoman
kathleen rice tweeting the time has come
the governor must resign six new york
socialist legislators are taking it a
step further
calling for cuomo's impeachment governor
cuomo has repeatedly abused his powers
and yet has faced no accountability and
as attorney general letitia james
conducts an independent investigation
new york city's democratic mayor drew a
line in the sand
if these allegations are true he
cannot govern while democratic majority
leader senator chuck schumer
refused to say if cuomo should resign
these women have to be listened to
now there's a investigation
in the hands of a very very capable
person the attorney general
of new york state i supported it and
called for it
other normally outspoken top democratic
women
like vice president kamala harris have
not said a word about cuomo's troubles
i can certainly speak on behalf of the
president and the vice president
and so let me reiterate that they both
believe that
every woman coming forward should be
heard today marked the one year
anniversary since governor cuomo's first
famous emmy award-winning coven 19
briefings
the facts defeat fear
because the reality is reassuring
it is deep breath time the briefings
propelled cuomo
into a media darling making appearances
on cnn with his brother
anchor chris cuomo was it this
was it this tell people the truth come
on love god
come on which one this is not love this
is not love
a year later a starkly different tone
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother
cnn says the early months the pandemic
were extraordinary times so they made a
one-time exception to the rule
barring chris from interviewing his
brother because
of its quote significant
human interest brett might have been
more than one time all right brian thank
you